oh my God I'm so honored that you would
come here yes although there was a time
where I was actually in your
home yes you were married to Tom Green
and you were house hunting and you came
I had a I was living in a house on
Outpost in the Hollywood Hills and my
house had actually probably burnt down
that was it yes you you there was a fire
and you had no home it was
yes it was very traumatizing and when
your house burned down almost everyone's
comment was isn't it sort of like
cleansing no and you're like no what the
hell are you talking about I just lost
everything that means anything to me
yeah cuz you
have all photos the everything my
passport that I had since I was a kid I
think that was the thing with all the
stamps of everywhere I'd been I'm like
you want to cleanse go get an enema this
is not that no this is trauma you I tell
you who ended up buying you who um Ben
Stiller really yeah and then he bought
next door that house and it was a huge
compound and I feel like it was on the
cover of el deor they did a lot of
design with it like he's that guy in
fact I love design too like I like
Zillow is porn pornography to me like
what is Zillow yeah yeah I just house
hunt all day long yeah my wife does that
she she kind of well I you know I'm
there sort of up over her shoulder kind
of guy that's nice well your wife and I
have a lot in common we love you and we
love
Zillow so we're off to a great start how
many boys do you have is it three I have
well four four a stepson William who's
15 so they go from
15 uh uh 24
2734 so what's it like to raise
boys first of all well the the the
middle what's the difference do you
think well the middle two I was a single
dad I'm a single mom right so at 42
years old I woke up you know sort of
divorced and I had custody of these
boys and um uh so that in itself was it
that was that was hard because there was
a shift in the industry where a lot of
Productions were being in it was Hungary
Budapest Prague for tax reasons yeah
Australia you know all these places
Vancouver yeah so I turned down a lot of
work thank God for Harry
Potter thank God for Harry Potter and
and I I tell you the two Batman and
Harry Potter
really they saved me because it meant
that I could I could do the least amount
of of work for the most amount of
money and then be home with the kids
actually it was when we did the first
Batman it London doubled for
Gotham and I did
27 round trips of flying back from La
I'd I'd fly in for a day I do a shoot a
day and Chris Nolan kindly said I said
look I'm in the car going back to the
airport if the da is if there's anything
wrong then I'll turn the car around but
you know where I'm going when we rrap
I'm on I'm in the car to the
airport and to his credit you know he he
stayed on
schedule and I would go home for three
days come back for two go home for a
weekend come back for one day go home
for a week come back for 4 days
otherwise I just felt they're being
brought up by
[Music]
nanny